สวัสดีค่ะครูอ้อยสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กอื
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนทุกๆคนนะคะวันนี้ครูปุ๊กและครูอ้อย
มาพบกับนักเรียนทุกคนในห้องเรียน
comprehensible  Thai ค่ะแล้วก็มาเรียน
ภาษาไทยกับที่ comprehensible ไทยค่ะเป็น
การเรียนแบบธรรมชาตินะคะนะแล้วก็วันนี้
วันอะไรคะครูอ้อยวันนี้วันพฤหัสสบดีค่ะ
อ่าวันพฤหัสสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
19 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนตุลาคมค่ะเดือน
ตุลาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือน
ที่ 10
อืมปีพุทธศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะพุทธศักราช
ที่
2566 ปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2023 ค่ะค่ะนะวันนี้ครูปุ๊กกับครูอ้อยก็
มาพบกับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะในวันพฤหัสสบดี
วันที่ 19 เดือนตุลาคมนะคะเป็นเดือนที่ 10
ปีพุทธศักราช
2566 ค่ะแล้วก็เป็นปีคริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะ
อืโปุ๊กสบายดีมั้ยคะสบายดีค่ะครูอ้อยล่ะ
คะทำไมดูครูอ้อยหนาวเหรอคะวันนี้ครูอ้อย
หนาววันนี้ครูอ้อยหนาวเดี๋ยวๆๆๆบ้านครู
ปุ๊กเนี่ยร้อนค่ะทำไมบ้านครูปุ๊กร้อนบ้าน
ครูอ้อยหนาวค่ะโอ้โหครูอ้อยคะบ้านครูปุ๊ก
เนี่ยโอ้โหคนไทยบอกว่าร้อนมากใช่มยร้อนจน
เหงื่อไหลค่ะติ๊งๆงติ๊งครูปุ๊กกับครูอ้อย
อยู่ประเทศเดียวกันหรือเปล่านั่นน่ะสิตอน
นี้ครูอ้อยอยู่ที่ไหนคะครูอ้อยอยู่
กรุงเทพฯค่ะครูปุ๊กก็อยู่กรุงเทพฯค่ะนะ
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้อุณหภูมิครูอ้อยก็ 23 องศา
ค่ะ
โอ้โหครูอ้อยคะ
ขาถึงทำไมครูอ้อยถึงหนาวครูอ้อยใช้
เครื่องปรับอากาศค่ะโอเปิดแ
เนี่ยเอ้ยแต่เดี๋ยวค่ะครูอ้อยครูคสครู
อ้อยเนี่ยผ้าที่พาดเนี่ยเป็นผ้าเข่าม้า
มั้ยคะอ๋อใช่ค่ะผ้าขาวม้าออเพราะว่าห่ม
สบายกุปุ๊ก
คือ 23 องาไม่ต้องไปใส่ขนเม้นเสื้อหนัง
ใช้ผ้าเนี่ยสบายอกำลังสบายเพราะว่าผ้า
เนื้อนิ่มมากนะเพราะว่าผ้าเขาม้าเนี่ย
โอ้โหคนไทยเนี่ยใช้มานานมากแล้วค่ะนะตั้ง
แต่เนู้นเลยค่ะย้อนไปนะไปยครูปุ๊บพูดนาน
มากนี่มันเหมือนนานแบบถึงสมัยสุโขทัยมั้ย
คะก่อนสุโขทัยค่ะก่อนมีสุโขทัยอีกค่ะนะ
เพราะฉะนั้นครูปุ๊ก็เลยบอกว่านานันานๆๆๆ
นานมากแล้วค่ะนะเพราะว่าสุโขทัยก็ 700
กว่าปีแล้วค่ะมากกว่า 700 ปีนะเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยอันนี้เนี่ยมาตั้งแต่ก่อน
สุโขทัยอีกนะครูปุ๊กผ้าเข่าไม้เนี่ยครู
อ้อยอ่ะเห็นนะมีเกือบทุกบ้านครูปุ๊กมี
มั้ยมีสิคะจะไม่มีได้อย่างไรมครูอ้อยบอก
แล้วว่ามีทุก์บ้านของครูปุ๊กเนี่ยไม่ใช่
มี 1 ด้วยค่ะครูอ้อยอุยไม่ได้มี 1 ผืนค่ะ
มีหลายผืนค่ะสีสวยด้วยครูปุ๊กใช่ค่ะ
นะนี่ค่ะเดี๋ยวตึ๊งๆผืนที่ 2 ค่ะ
จผืนที่ 3
ค่ะเดี๋ยวครูปุ๊กเป็นร้านขายผ้าเขาไมหรือ
เปล่าไม่ๆๆไม่ได้เป็นแต่ว่าสีสวยค่ะเลย
ชอบค่ะครูอ้อยเห็นมยสีสวยมยอืสวยค่ะอือ
ใช่นะจริงๆสีเนี่ยเยอะมากๆเลยเนาะครูอ้อย
โหเวลาไปซื้อเนี่ยเลือกไม่ถูกเลยสีมัน
เยอะแค่
นี้ทุกบ้านต้องมีครูปุ๊กมีเยอะเลยมีเยอะ
หลายผืนอือใช่เพราะว่าตอนแรกตอนแรกที่เรา
ซื้อเนี่ย้าจะอาจจะแข็งนิดนึงแต่พอซักซัก
ๆบ่อยๆเนาะครูอ้อยผ้าจะนิ่มอืมนะนิ่มอื
ใช่แล้วคนไทยเนี่ยไม่ได้ใช้แค่ผ้าเข่าม้า
เนี่ยเออใช้ทำอะไรบ้างอ่ะไม่ใช่ห่มแค่แบบ
ครูอ้อยใช่มั้ยเขาบอกว่าคนไทยเนี่ยเขาบอก
เขาบอกบอืผ้าเข่าม้าเนี่ยคือผ้าสารพัด
ประโยชน์ออทำได้ทุกอย่างครูปุ๊กเ้าครู
อ้อยอากาศเย็นหนาว
อร้อนร้อนใช่มั้ยครูปุ๊กเหงื่อออกค่ะ
อ๋อซับเหงื่อได้ใ่โอหพอกลางคืนยุงเยอะครู
ปุ๊กยุง
มันจะตุ๊บกัดใช่มยกูปุ๊กยุงเยอะยุงกูปุ๊ก
ไปไหนละครูปุ๊กกินยุงมา
ละก็นี่เลยครูปุ๊กพอยุงมาใช่มยจะเข้ามาออ
นะปัดยุงปัดแมลงก็ได้ปัดยุงปัดไม่ให้มัน
กัดเราปัดอือฮึ
นะแล้วถ้าเผื่อกลางคืนเข้าบ้านและไปไหว้
พระปุบๆบเอาวางไว้แล้วก็กราบพ่ะเอาวางไว้
กับพื้นน่ะอืคนไทยเนาะแล้วก็กราบ
ลงบอกไงว่าจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยผ้าเขาม้าเนี่ย
มีประโยชน์มากๆเนาะครูอ้อยนะหลายๆคนเนี่ย
จะเห็นเวลาผู้ชายนะนอยู่บ้านนะใส่นุ่งนะ
แทไม่ใส่กางเกง
ได้าเ่าไม้าอย่างเดียวใช่มยครแล้วก็เดิน
ประเทศไทยร้อนไงอลมมันเย็นเราก็ใส่เนาะ
แต่เราใช้กับตัวเนี้ยเราไปใช้อย่างอื่น
ได้นะคุณปุ๊กออ้อยเปิดภาพให้คุณปุ๊กดูว่า
ถ้าเขาม้าเนี่ยเราเอาไปใช้อย่างอื่นได้
อะไรบ้างได้เลยค่ะเปิดมาเลยค่ะเราจะได้
รู้ว่ามันสารพัดประโยชน์ยังไงครูปุ๊กเห็น
สาวสวยคนนี้มยอ่ะเห็นแล้วค่ะเคไปเที่ยว
แล้วเค้าก็อยากถ่ายรูปสวยๆอือแล้วแล้ว
พื้นมันไม่สะอาดอ่ะอยากจะนอนถ่ายสวยๆเขา
ก็เอาผ้าเขามาปูพื้นแล้วก็นอนถ่ายนะแสดง
ว่าถ้านักเรียนเนาะไปไปทะเลอ่าแล้วก็เอา
ผ้าเขาม้าปูที่ชายหาดนะแล้วก็นอนฝรั่งบาง
คนชอบอาบแดดไงนะจะปูนอนได้นะปูนอนได้ใช่
ค่ะแล้วทำอะไรได้อีกนอกจากปูนอนเนี่ยนะก็
ปูโต๊ะไงคะออปูโต๊ะอุ๊ยเา้าทำสวยด้วยนะ
อุ๊ยแล้วก็เด็กๆทำด้วยอ่ะครูอ้อยใชเ้ามี
งานกูปุ๊กมันไม่ผืนเดียวเเอาหลายๆผืนมา
ต่อกันแล้วทำสวยนะทำลายสวยนะอือันนี้
เนี่ยเหมือนเราไปตามโรงแรมเนาะนะแบบโรง
แรมแบบ 5 ดาวเค้าก็จะเวลาทำโต๊ะทำอะไรเ
ต้องทำให้สวยๆต้องมีผ้าคุมนะแต่ครูอ้อย
ว่านี่คืองานโรงเรียนใช่ค่ะอาจจะมีแจจัด
กิจกรรมจัดประชุมหรือจัดเลี้ยงอะไรสัก
อย่างแล้วก็เด็กก็เอาภ้าเขาม้าไทยนี่แหละ
แหละมาทำปู
โต๊ะที่บ้านถ้าอยากให้แบบเออสวยๆก็เอาผ้า
ลายสวยๆทำเป็นผ้าปูโต๊ะได้นะปุ๊กใช่เพราะ
ว่ามีให้เลือกเยอะค่ะหลายสีเนาะนะแล้วแต่
เราเราชอบเลยไปงานเลี้ยงปูโต๊ะสวยแล้ว
เก้าอี้ก็ต้องสวยครูปุ๊กเอ้ายังไงคะอนี่
ไงเก้าอี้ที่นั่งนะขงหลังโบว์แต่งสวยอืม
ก็สวยดีเนาะครูอ้อยสวยมากคือแบบเราเห็น
เออผ้าเขาม้าใช้ได้นะทำสวยแล้วก็มันก็ดู
ดีขึ้นใช่ไม่ใช่เก้าอี้ธรรมดานะมันก็ดู
เป็นเก้าอี้ที่แบบพิเศษขึ้นมาเลยดีขึ้น
เลยค่ะสวยค่ะนะอ่าหลังจากนั้นก็นี่เลย
ค่ะอะไเรามีลูกเล็กๆนะเอเอ๊กล่อมนอนนะก็
เอาผ้าเขาม้าเนี่ยมาผูกกับเสาใช้เชือกผูก
หรือมัดนะกับเสาแล้วก็เอาเด็กึงเนี่ยเอา
เด็กลงนอนแล้วก็เปไขว่อ๋อทำเป็นเปลย
สำหรับเด็กเล็กๆเนาะที่เกิดแล้วก็อุ๊ย
เนี่ยก็ใส่ลงไปแล้วก็นอนแล้วก็แกว่งหรือ
ไกวเปยนะให้เด็กเ่ะนอนหลับสบายนะตอนเด็ก
เด็กๆเนาะเด็กๆไทยเนี่ยจะได้นอนแบบเนี้ย
ใช่ค่ะเป็นส่วนมากเลยอ่ะครุณปุ๊กอแน่นอน
ค่ะเนาะก็เราก็เอาไปทำเป็นเปลยได้ด้วย
โอ้สารพัดประโยชน์จริงๆหมดหรือยังคะ
ประโยชน์ยังๆๆยังไม่ยังไม่หมดค่ะยังมีอีก
มากอืืเหมือนอย่างที่เนี่ยอากาศเย็นๆนะ
เอาๆถ้าไม่อากาศเย็นๆเอาเท่ก็
ได้พันอ๋อสำรองใส่ถ่ายรูปอ้าพันธุสวยๆนะ
ก็ดีนะเพราะว่าพัน
คอถ้าอากาศไม่ร้อนเนาะก็เอาพันคอเย็นก็
ทันอย่างงี้ไม่ใช่
พันอย่างงี้ไม่เอาอันนี้อันนี้เรียกว่า
พันค่ะแค่นี้อเอาผ้าพันเข้าไป 1000  1000
แต่ถ้าถ้าอย่างงี้เนี่ยต้องผูกล่ะค่ะครู
อ้อยผูกถ้า
มัดผูกอือ้ายังไม่หมดครูปุ๊ก
อ่าเป็นผ้าผูกเอวอ้าถ้าอย่างนี้คือผูกนะ
ครูปุ๊กใช่เอาปลายกับปลายมาผูก
อ่าผูกเอวมันติดกันเนาะอสมัยก่อนเราไม่มี
เข็ม
ขัดคนไทยจะนุ่งกางเกงข้างในแล้วก็ใช้ผ้า
เนี่ยผูก
เอวผ้าเขาม้าผูกเอวนะกางเกงจะได้ไม่หลุด
ไงไม่งั้นูเซ็กซี่ค่ะนะก็ล็อคกางเกงเอา
ไว้เนาะ
เออแล้วประโยชน์มีอะไรอีกออนี่ไงง่ายๆเลย
เนาะ
คุมคุมหัว
อเพราะว่าแดดร้อนหยคุมแบบครูอ้อยไม่สวย
ค่ะต้องคุมแบบเค้าค่ะต้องคุมแบบเค้าต้อง
คุมอย่างงี้แต่ครูอ้อยเนี่ยถ้าไปสวนนะไป
สวนปลูกต้นไม้ก็คุมอย่างงี้เลยคุณ
ปุ๊กครูอ้อยมีออกซินมั้ยแดดกันแดดกัน
โควิดกันฝุ่นค่ะอืเวลาเราไปแต่แต่ใส่
อย่างงี้อย่าไปธนาคารนะ
คะเดี๋ยวเจ้าหน้าที่ตกใจเดี๋ยวยามจะมาปิด
ๆเข้าไม่ได้
ครับอันนี้คุมหัว
นะแสดงว่าเวลาแดดร้อนๆเนาะมีแสงแดดร้อนๆ
เนี่ยเราก็เอามาคุมไม่ต้องใส่หมวกก็ได้
ใช่มยใช่ก็อเราไม่ต้องใส่หมวกก็ได้เราคุม
หัวแต่เราจะทำเป็นหมวกก็ได้อ่ะได้ด้วยหรอ
คะครูอ้อยโอโหสารพัดประโยชน์นี่ไงอืมเออ
สวยด้วยทำเป็นหมวกคนนี้กำลังนั่งทำเลยอ่า
อืสวยเนาะใช่โอ้นะก็เพราะว่าหมวกประเภท
เนี้ยเวลาทำงานน่ะกลางแดดอ่ะมันมีเหงื่อ
ไงมันสามารถเอาเหงื่อที่จะตกลงมาที่หน้า
เนี่ยขอบเขาจะรับเหงื่อไปหมด้าเข่าม้าถ้า
อย่างงั้นเนี่ยเวลาเทนนิสไปเล่นเทนนิสก็
ใส่แบบนี้ก็ได้ค่ะไม่ต้องมี่าคาดกทำแล้ว
ขายให้กับนัก
เทนนิสเดี๋ยวเอ่อผ้าคาดหัวสำหรับนัก
เทนนิสไทยจะออกทั่วโลกเป็น้าเขาม้าเออ
เข้าท่านะเออ
นะไม่ต้องไปซื้อของยี่ห้อแพงๆนะใช่โอ้โหย
ผืนของประเทศไทยเนี่ยภาคเขาม้าเนี่ยมี
ราคาตั้งแต่ 70 บาท 80 บาท
180  160 มีหลายราคามากแล้วก็มีถึง
300  200  500 ก็ยังมีคุณปุ๊กอ๋อจริงๆ
แล้วอ่ะมันขึ้นอยู่กับขนาดใช่มยเล็กใหญ่
ใช่มยแล้วก็ความยาวแล้วก็แล้วก็เนื้อผ้า
เนื้อผ้านะเป็นพันก็มีค่ะหลักพันก็มีต้อง
ทำมาจากผ้าไหมนะเป็นเป็นไทยซิลเนาะผ้า
ใหม่อืแต่ว่ามีแค่นี้หรอคะครูอ้อยหมดอ่า
ยังๆยังไม่หมดแต่จะบอกครูปุ๊กว่าพอทำเป็น
หมวกใช่มเราเรียกโพกโพกหัวอือือือ่ะ
อันเนี้ยคัว
ชอบอันนี้เป็นซุปเปอร์สตาเราเลยนะค่ะอัน
นี้น่าจะเป็นภาพในหนังเนาะหรือในละครเา
ใส่นุ่งอาบน้ำนะออคนต่างจังหวัดบางครั้ง
เนี่ยไม่ได้อาบน้ำในห้องน้ำนะครูปุ๊กค่ะ
เราจะออกน้ำอาบน้ำหรือตักน้ำจากท่าน้ำ
หรือไม่ก็มีตุ่มใหญ่ๆตักอาบ
แล้วก็ผู้ชายก็จะใส่ผ้าเขาม้านุ่งแล้วก็
อาบแบบนี้เลยค่ะนะเพราะว่าจะได้ไม่
เซ็กซี่เนาะนะก็จะต้องใส่คลุมไว้เพราะว่า
มันไม่มีห้องที่ปิดไม่มีประตูนะเพราะว่า
โอ้โหห้องน้ำเป็นแบบธรรมชาติค่ะก็ดีนะบาง
คนอาจจะชอบผู้ชายอาจจะชอบเพราะว่าได้เห็น
วิวได้เห็นทุกคนอ่าสบายๆนะอากาศดีเอออ่า
ไม่อยากจะผ่านภาพนี้ไปเลยค่ะอ่านไปก่อน
ค่ะอะไรคะเนี่ยสมมุติว่าครูปุ๊กอ่ะมีลูก
เล็กๆนะแล้วครูปุ๊กจะต้องกล่อมเ้านอนครู
ปุ๊กอ่ะเมื่อยมือเนาะอุ้มอ่ะแล้วก็ใช้ผ้า
ช่วยผ้าเขาม้าช่วยคล้องแบบเนี้ยรับน้ำ
หนักของลูกเออนะจะได้ไม่เจ็บแล้วก็เวลา
ลูกหลับแล้วก็เอาทางภาคเข่าหม้าไปเลยยกไป
วางแล้วก็่ถอดออกแกแล้วก็วางเด็กก็จะได้
รู้สึกแบบไม่ตื่นน่ะไม่เออโอ้โหเมื่อก่อน
นี้เนี่ยกูปุ๊กต้องอุ้มแบบนี้ค่ะพอลูก
ร้องโคลิกเนี่ยเวลาหลับเนี่ยวางยากมากเลย
นะพออุ้มไว้อย่างเงี้ยแล้วพอพอวางปุ๊บก็
ตื่นแวงแวะเราก็ต้องไปอุ้มขึ้นมาอีกอือฮึ
อ้อยว่าถ้าห่อด้วยผ้าเนี่ยมันแบบเค้าจะมี
ความรู้สึกเค้ามีรับสัมผัสที่แขนอยู่ไง
ที่ตัวอยู่ว่ามันมีความอบอุ่นของแม่เน
แล้วก็ค่อยๆวางอาฮะก็เอาไว้อุ้มเด็กได้
ค่ะออไว้อุ้มลูกใชอ่ะอันนี้คือสมมุติถ้า
จะอุ้มเด็กนอนนะแต่เวลาเราทำงานบ้านูก
ปุ๊บค่ะเราก็อุ้มแบบนี้ได้ไงคุณปุ๊กเอน่า
รัก
เชอะทำงานไปแล้วเค้าก็อยู่ข้างหลังเราไป
ดูเราทำงานเคครูอ้อยว่าเ้าจะสนุกด้วยนะ
แม่ทำอะไรล้างจานตากผ้ากวาดบ้านเอาลูก
อยู่กับตัวอ่าเด็กจะได้ไม่หายไปไหนเนาะ
บางคนเนี่ยแม่ทำงานหันมาอีกทีลูกหายไป
ไหนลูกคานไปรู่เลยคานไปไหนแล้วก็ไม่รู้
นี่นี่ๆๆคนนี้น่ารักมากเห็นมยอเห็นมั้ย
ประโยชน์ผ้าเขาม้านี่เยอะมากเลยเนาะครู
อ้อยเนาครูปุ๊กครูอ้อยอ่ะมีผืนเดียว
สารพัดประโยชน์ค่ะนี่ๆคนนี้เ้าไปวัดกันไง
ครูปุ๊กไปทำบุญที่วัดอาต่อมาไปด้วยเนี่ย
อันเนี้ยเหมือนกับที่ครูอ้อยอ่ะทำให้ครู
ปุ๊กดูตอนตอนแรกผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงถ้าพลาด
อย่างเงี้ยแล้วเวลาเไปนั่งไหว้พระอ่ะเขา
จะเอาผ้าวางกับผืนเนี่ยผ้าจักไหลเคุณปุ๊ก
อืวางกับพื้นแล้วเวลาก้มกราบพระเนี่ยเรา
ก็กราบกับพื้นเพราะว่าเวลากราบเนี่ยต้อง
แบมือติดลงไปเนาะก็เลยต้องมีเอาผ้าไปวาง
เพื่อให้มันดูดีสุภาพอือึค่ะคนไทยเนามัน
เป็นเหมือนวัฒนธรรมเหมือนมันดูดูสุภาพ
อย่างที่ครูปุ๊กบอกอืนะนี่ผู้หญิงผู้ชาย
ก็นุ่งแบบผ้าพันเนาะบางทีก็พันมันเหมือน
กางเกงเลยนะใช่ค่ะเขาจะเอาชายของผ้าเนี่ย
ขอโทษค่ะสอดนะเอาชายของผ้าเนี่ยพาดเอา
ข้ามไปข้างหลังค่ะนะแล้วก็เอาไปล็อคไว้
ข้างหลังนะเพื่อให้มันเป็นเหมือนกางเกงนะ
มันจะได้ใส่สบายบางในสมัยก่อนเขาจะใส่อาบ
น้ำที่ในแม่น้ำอืมันจะได้ไม่หลุดไม่
เซ็กซี่เนาะก็เอาล็อคเอาไว้เห็นมั้ย
เหมือนผู้ชายคนเถ้าเใส่เป็น
กางเกงใช่ค่ะเขาจะเอาผ้าที่อยู่ข้างหน้า
เนี่ยสอดกเอาขาข้ามไปข้างนึงแล้วก็เอาไป
ล็อคไว้กับข้างหลังค่ะแล้วก็หญิไทสมัย
ก่อนเนี่ยเขาก็จะใส่สำหรับเป็นแทนเสื้อ
อ่ะค่ะใส่สบายๆเพราะว่าอากาศมันร้อนเนาะ
ใช่ก็ใส่ผ้าถุงแล้วตัวนี้ก็นุ่งสบายๆแต่
อย่างสำหรับผู้ชายเนี่ยถ้าใส่เป็นกางเกง
เมื่อไหร่เนี่ยเตรียมพร้อมทำงานหลายอย่าง
เลยอือหือลงน้ำหาปลาปีนต้นไม้ทำสวนทำไร่
ทำนาได้ทุกอย่างได้หรือว่ามวยก็เมื่อก่อน
เออใช่ต่อยมวยต่อยมวยชกมวยมวยไทยสมัยก่อน
ไม่มีกางเกงอย่างปัจจุบันเนาะก็อใช่ก็
อันเนี้ย่ะค่ะใช้ผ้าเขาม้า
นะแล้วสมัยก่อนเนี่ยผู้หญิงไทยเนี่ย
อันเนี้ยอันเนี้ยมันไม่ใช่เราจะไ่เงี้ย
เป็นผ้าตะเบ็งมารแต่เป็นใช้ผ้าเขาม้านะคะ
คือบางครั้งเสื้อข้างในมันอาจจะบางสีขาว
เนอะแล้วเขาคก็จะเอาผ้าเขาม้ามาพาดปิด
อือันนี้ก็เป็นแบบ
โอ้โหสมัยก่อนไม่มีเป็นเอ่อเสื้อชั้นในไง
ครูอ้อยไม่มีบลานะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยถ้าผ้า
เป็นสีขาวอาจจะดูเซ็กซี่ก็เลยทำเป็น
ตะเบ็งมารเป็นคลุมไว้คลุมไว้นะฮะโอ้โหอัน
นี้สีเยอะมากเลยครูอ้อยนี่ไงเพราะว่าเค้า
เนี่ยทำผ้าเขาม้ามาหลายสีและลวดลายสวยคือ
มันเป็นตารางแหละแต่เขาใช้หลายสีทำให้มัน
สวยไงแล้วปัจจุบันเนี้ยคนไทยก็พยายามเอา
มาทำอย่างอื่นเอามาทำเสื้อผ้าแบบสวยๆครู
ปุ๊กอื
นี่เสื้อผ้าแบบสวยๆนะใส่แบบสวยเลยตอนนี้
ดีไซน์เนอร์เ้าออกแบบมาเนี่ยแล้วก็ทำขาย
เนี่ยเป็นชุดสวยๆเนี่ยโอ้โหเพิ่มมูลมูล
เพิ่มราคาค่ะนะอย่าง้าที่ครูอ้อยบอกว่า
บางทีเนี่ย 100 กว่าบาทแต่พอตัดเป็นชุด
เนี่ยอาจจะได้โอ้โหเกือบ 1,000 นึงอย่าง
เงี้ยหรือ 1,000 บาทเงี้ยเออก็นะก็ดีค่ะ
นะนี่อันนี้เป็นเหมือนอื้อหือดูดีเลยทั้ง
เสื้อทั้งกระเป๋าเลยอเนี่ยผ้าเข่าม้าเลย
เสื้อแบบเป็นดูเป็นพันกว่าขึ้นแน่นอนครู
ปุ๊ก 1000 กว่านี่คือ 1,000 บาทนะ 1,000
บาทขึ้นไปก็คืออันเนี้ยสไตล์แบบเนี้ยเป็น
คิดถึงคนญี่ปุ่นค่ะผู้หญิงญี่ปุ่นที่ดูไฮ
คลาสหน่อยอ่ะเขาคจะใส่เป็นผ้าไหมเนแล้วก็
มีกระเป๋าเป็นชุดกับเสื้อค่ะเป็นเสื้อ
คลุมแล้วก็ข้างในเป็นแสกเป็นชุดแซกเนาะอื
อ่านอกจากไปทำเสื้อผ้าแล้วของบางอย่าง
เขาคก็ทำแบบพวกพวงกุญแจอือ
กระเป๋าหรือหรือไม่ก็อันนี้ที่ที่วางที่
วางพวกหม้อร้อนๆ
อืหรือสุอะไรอย่างเงี้เนาะแบบอันนี้น่าจะ
เป็นไม่เข็มขัดเข็มขัดหรือป่ะเข็มขดเข็ม
ขัดรัดเอวอือือค่ะนะโอทำเป็นกระเป๋าแบบ
ใส่มือถือก็ได้นะใช่โทรศัพท์กระเป๋าเล็กๆ
อืค่ะเหมือนอย่างเหมือนอย่างเยครูอ้อยก็
ซื้อมา
ค่ะเป็น
กระเป๋าก็ใส่สำหรับใส่เครื่องสำอางก็ได้
ใส่พวกสายชาร์จโทรศัพท์อะไเครื่องสำอางก็
คือพวกลิปสติกนะเป็นแป้งอือายแชโดวนะหรือ
ว่าบัชออนอะไรแบบเนี้ยค่ะก็ใส่เนลงไปใน
กระเป๋าเล็กๆได้อืเวลาปกแล้วที่อันนี้ครู
อ้อยชอบมากเลยครูปุ๊ก
อืมสวยค่ะเป็นร่มทำเป็นร่มแต่อันนี้
สำหรับกันแดดนะนักเรียนกันผนน่าจะไม่ได้
ค่ะกันฝนไม่ได้นะต่อไปอนาคตอาจจะไปเคลือบ
อะไรสักอย่างเพื่อให้กันฝนได้ใช่นะอันนี้
ก็เป็นร่มค่ะเอาไปทำเป็นร่มอสวยอืนะเห็น
มยพมีหลายสีไงแล้วเป็นอะไรอีกเป็นเป็น
อะไรอีกเป็นของฝากอือของขวัญก็ได้ของฝาก
ก็ได้นะของฝัก็คือไม่ว่าจะเป็นวันเกิด
เพื่อนนะอ่าหรือว่าเอ่อไม่รู้แต่งงานใช้
ได้มั้ย
อ่านะแต่ของฝากก็คือถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศ
ไทยแล้วไม่รู้จะซื้ออะไรไปไปให้เพื่อนไป
ให้พ่อแม่ญาติพี่น้องเนาะก็อาจจะคิดถึง
ผ้าเขามาก็ได้นะก็ทำเป็นห่อสวยงามค่ะนะ
แล้วก็ราคาก็ไม่ได้แพงมากนะเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยเลือกค่ะว่าจะเอาอะไรเพราะว่าจริงๆ
แล้วอ่ะเราสามารถไปประยุกต์ไปปรับเปลี่ยน
ทำอะไรก็ได้หลายอย่างหรือว่าอย่างที่
หน้าต่างใช่มยนักเรียนมีหน้าต่างแล้วก็
กันแดดได้กันแสงได้อืหรืออย่างถ้าถ้าครู
ถ้าครูอ้อยชอบเข้าเข้าครัวนะครูปุ๊กเข้า
ครัวก็พลาดไว้แล้วเวลายกหม้อร้อนๆยกจาน
ร้อนๆนี่
ไงใช้นี่เลยใช้เนี่ยทำเป็นถุงมือเลยแล้ว
ก็ยกอืช่วยได้
เลยนึกว่าครูอ้อยจะมาทำเป็นแบบผ้าแบบกัน
เปื้อนอ้าได้ได้ได้นะไม่ใช่ได้เอทำได้ทุก
อย่างอืใช่ผ้าเช็ดมือก็ได้สวยอทีนี้พอพอ
มันเริ่ม
เก่าเริ่มเก่าเริ่มมีขาาดแล้ว้ามันดีเชค
พื้นซับน้ำดีมากใชู่พื้นอือือืเป็นผ้าคี
ริ้วเราเรียกผ้าคีริ้วนะเวลาเราไม่ใช้
แล้วคือถูพื้นอือเป็นผ้าเช็ดเท้าก็ได้ครู
ปุ๊กอืเหมือนออกจากห้องน้ำเนอาบน้ำเสร็จ
น้ำเปียกอยู่เนาะเรามีผ้าเช็ดตัวแล้วเช็ด
ตัวแล้วแต่ว่าขาเนี่ยอาจจะเท้าเนี่ยยัง
เปียกอยู่เนาะก็อาจจะมีเอาปูพื้นไว้ข้าง
นอกแล้วก็เช็ดอบนพาขีริ้วที่เป็นผ้าเขา
ม้าเนาะที่เราใช้งานนานแล้วเพราะว่ามัน
ซับน้ำได้ดีซับน้ำก็คือหมายถึงว่ามันจะ
ดูดน้ำเทน้ำไปแล้วแล้วมันก็ดูดน้ำได้ดีอ
นะเหมือนๆทิชชู่นะเวลาหมดหรือยังเนี่ยคุณ
ปุ๊กอีกนิดนึงค่ะอีกนิดนึงเวลาไปต่าง
จังหวัดที่อากาศไม่หนาวมากๆปุ๊กติดไปผืน
เดียวอๆไปทำอะไรคะเอ้าไปห่มนอน
ถ้าเราไปนอนปกกลางเต็นท์นอนหรืออะไรเงี้ย
ห่มนอนอื
โอนอกจากห่มนอนแล้วมีอีกผืนนึงทำอะไรคะ
โห
หนุนแทนหมอนเนอะเวลาเราแทนหมอนเอ่าเพราะ
ผ้าค่อนข้างไม่ได้เล็กนะครูปุ๊กผืนนึง
เป็นมาตรฐานนี่ก็ใหญ่นะอือฮึใหญ่อยู่ค่ะ
แล้วก็ยาวยาวอืจริงๆมันมีหลายขนาดเนาะนม
ยาวอยู่ค่ะยาวอยู่ทางนี้
ค่ะอันนี้
กว้างยาเห็นูเห็นครูปุ๊กมีหลายสีเนี่ย
เดี๋ยวครูอ้อยจะไปซื้อเพิ่ม
ละ 4 ูอ้อยว่าครูอ้อยมีน้อยไปอปุ๊กมีมากๆ
ครูอ้อยมีน้อยไปใช่เป็นแฟชั่นได้ค่ะครู
อ้อยใช่นะก็ผ้าเขาม้าเราเนี่ยสารพัด
ประโยชน์ใช่มั้ยมีประโยชน์มากๆนะคนคนไทย
เนี่ยเราก็เลยใช้กันมากๆค่ะนะก็ใช้ทุก
บ้านเนี่ยหลายๆบ้านโดยเฉพาะยิ่งต่าง
จังหวัดเนี่ยจะมีแน่นอนนะก็โดยเฉพาะผู้
ชายเนาะผู้ชายเนี่ยจะใช้มากกว่าผู้หญิง
ค่ะนะผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะใช้น้อยกว่าแต่ตอนนี้
เนี่ยเนื่องจากว่าเราไปเปลี่ยนเป็นเสื้อ
ทำเป็นเสื้อทำเป็นกระโปรงทำได้หลายอย่าง
ก็เลยกลายเป็นแฟชั่นที่ตอนนี้เนี่ยอาจจะ
มีคนเนี่ยนิยมทำหรือว่าชอบทำกันมากๆเนาะ
ใช่อืวันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วล่ะครูปุ๊ค่ะอาจ
จะต้องลานักเรียนให้นักเรียนรู้จัก
ประโยชน์ของผ้าขาม้าไปแล้ววันนี้อืนะก็
นักเรียนก็ไปซื้อได้ค่ะผ้าเขาม้านะผ้าเขา
ม้าเนี่ยมีขายเยอะเลยค่ะสั่งตามออนไลน์ก็
ได้เนาะอ่าก็มีขายเหมือนกันโอเควันนี้ก็
หมดเวลาแล้วแล้วก็เดี๋ยวเรามาพบกันใหม่ใน
คลิปต่อไปนะคะแล้วก็ใครที่มีผ้าเขาม้าใช้
คอมเมนต์บอกเราด้วยด้วยค่ะว่าใช้ประโยชน์
อะไรจากผ้าเข่าม้าได้บ้างนะถ่ายรูปให้ดู
ได้ก็ดีนะคะใช่ค่ะนะแล้วก็โอกาสหน้าเรามา
พบกันใหม่ค่ะขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ